hooker gets around pal now he's got to
engage with zubats who backs off with
biombo the spin the dudes
Morris catches after the deflection
Gordon it's off Jordan yet to score a
leak out
on the work attack
Westford over Beyond Oh short one and
done
Booker he checked
but then it transition Let it Fly Young
fella Let it Fly
[Music]
away scooped up by Booker crosses
[Applause]
in playoff mode they go right back to
the same play the victim rolls this time
Powell jumps up
he's putting on a show
Norman Powell is upset that the help
wasn't there hooker swing
corner of kogi crosses and kicks buffer
beats the shot clock
Kevin Booker is in the zone
the Phoenix Suns advance
to the second round
they hold off the clippers in game five
to wrap up the series